I find it helpful to think of the memory system as a pipe.
Threads issuing requests stuff memory transactions into that pipe.
For example, these could be load instructions to read in a certain address in memory.
And the result of that transaction eventually falls out the bottom of the pipe, to head back to those threads.
Now, the pipe is really deep. It takes 200 or 300 clock cycles for a transaction to move through this pipe.
And the pipe is also really thick and wide.
Okay, it's designed to be filled with many transactions at the same time
from lots of SM's running lots of threads.
So when you only have a few threads issuing transactions, the pipe is mostly empty.
This could happen, for example, if you don't have all of your SM's, actively filled with threads that
are issuing transactions, or if the latency between the transactions coming from each thread is too high.
So if we only have a few threads issuing transactions,
the pipe is mostly empty and not many bytes are being delivered.
And Little's law tells us that if not many bytes are being delivered,
then our total bandwidth is going to suffer.
So you can make this better by having more threads issuing memory transactions,
or by having more memory in flight per thread.
So here's one of those strategies.
This is measured data from taking a GPU and copying a bunch of data
from one matrix to another, just like we're doing.
And the important thing to notice is that we're doing it in 3 different styles.
We're doing a 4 byte word--so this is the equivalent
of a single precision floating point, which is what our code is doing--
an 8 byte word--for example, if we were moving double precision floating point around,
that's what we would be getting--or a 16 byte word.
And there exist in CUDA data types in the 4, 8, and 16 byte, variety.
For example, float, which is what we've been using so far,
float 2, which is 2 adjacent floating point numbers, float 4, which is 4 adjacent floating point numbers.
And so one option that we could do
is we could try to restructure our code around the idea of having a single
thread pull in 4 floating point numbers at a time and do its transpose on that.
That would move us up from this line.
In terms which is a percent of achieved bandwidth, up to this line, that's a healthy increase.
On the other hand, the sort of torquing the code around to do something that's less natural--
like manipulate 4 single floating point values at a time--
in this case, it's not a particularly natural thing to do.
What we have coming in--an array of floating point numbers or a matrix of floating point numbers.
And to read them 4 at a time, in little bitty rows, and transpose those into little
bitty columns, we can certainly do it, but I think it borders on a Ninja topic.
While this would help, this is the kind of Ninja optimization that will prove useful.
I don't think that it's vital. Let's talk about other things that we can do.
So if we can't make all of our memory transactions wider very easily,
then we can try to have more transactions.
Let's have a quiz.
Which of our transpose kernels, so far, probably suffer from too few transactions?
Our first version had a single thread for the entire matrix.
Our next version had a single thread for every row of the matrix.
Our third version had a single thread for every element,
and our fourth version was tiled.
Check those which probably suffered from too few transactions.